your accent is so adorable you could
forget to say anything at all and just
turn those vowels in two words way up
there were like 18 A's in that word
you're awesome now at its core Ubisoft
as a creative company with an
independent spirit and support for
innovative projects is a part of its DNA
but every once in a while that DNA
mutates slightly and this happens
thank you thank you thank you thank you
where's chat not you out late so I'm
sorry I'm just kidding I'm just gonna
hello I'm I'll tell ever saw the
creative director of trials and also
president of Finland hello i'm dean
evans creative director of the original
blood dragon and advocate of world peace
trials and blood dragon made baby
together
that's right auntie and this horrible
problem child is being delivered right
now now
risk our cold and dr. darling are back
this time with their to cyber commando
kids Roxanne and Slater play is the
happiest me huge the side of ours defy
gravity on your ultimate dragon slayer
cyber bites protect America with Rita
flips and wide on the rack Nicholas
roller coaster out of righteousness
grapple it's been all over the planet
use guns to shoot cyborgs communist
aliens and die an ancient dragon ball
space is the place and the engine is in
your pain right through loops boots and
multiple dimensions it's the future come
fight me lot more for
together forever today trials of the
blood dragon
twinkle you believe an extremely turkeys
nothing like an 8-bit title to get you
excited as you can tell this game is a
beast and in case you didn't get the
incredibly subtle messaging in that
video it is out now on pc playstation 4
and xbox one well actually it's almost
out now we didn't want anybody sprinting
off the Chiefs blood dragons when we
were still here on stage so the game
will be released as soon as this
conference ends about 30 minutes from
now calm yourselves and just take
comfort in the fact that apparently
LMFAO was back together guys so that was
nice alright